[Music]
freedom day was for some the first
opportunity to go clubbing in their
lives and perhaps their first
dabble with illegal substances but
authorities are warning of heightened
risk
after two clubbers died and a number
ended up in hospital last weekend
possibly because of a dangerous batch of
ecstasy circulating in the uk
here in bristol one man died and 20 were
treated in hospital
it's because of the gravity of this
problem that one drug dealer we're
calling sasha
has agreed to meet us
he has with him a kilo of what he
purchased as
ecstasy on the dark web but is in fact a
different potentially more dangerous
substance
we've agreed to protect his identity in
order to get an inside perspective
on what's happening normally i think
that the dark web
is a more secure place to buy drugs
because of the customer ratings
and you can read reviews and stuff but i
guess you know accidents can happen
maybe the guy sold us this he got
screwed over by his supplier
a simple test brings out a black color
on real ecstasy while this fake
substance comes up blue
even though they look identical users
wouldn't know
and nor can they tell by sight the
strength of any particular pill
does it play on your conscience that
some of the stuff that you're selling
could end up killing people well yeah
that's why i'm doing this now
because i want to help get the message
out there that not everything you get is
safe
even if you think it's from a reliable
source like we did yeah
could be dangerous do you therefore then
think to yourself well maybe i shouldn't
be in this business
yeah good question i try to do as
responsibly as i can
jack and tauren lakeman both died on the
same night in december 2014 in
manchester
after taking an overdose of ecstasy
their father ray
thinks the drug market should be
regulated and taken away from dealers
like sasha there have been so many who
have died since my boys have died
and i see these debts as being
preventable
and we're not going to prevent it by
turning around and saying
let's continue the same way that we've
always done let's carry on with this
misuse of drugs act which has been you
know in effect since 1971
and the deaths are going up bristol
clubs have put warnings out about the
dangerous pills on social media feeds
but it's not something but some
campaigners say testing systems
should be put in place to make drug use
safer
drug checking is a sensible policy i
don't think people are going to
take more ecstasy because they can go
and get their tablets tested
more that people who use that drug and
might be using it unsafely will be able
to use it
more safely also they'll be engaging
with services with drug workers who know
what they're doing sasha isn't selling
what would amount to 10
000 doses and could earn him thousands
of pounds
it's being safely disposed of but
authorities warn
there are batches in circulation that
are more dangerous
than users think jason farrell sky news